all right so this is a real thought in
the Jurassic Park movie Jurassic Park is
frightening in the dark all the
dinosaurs are running wild
someone shut the cancer in the ring nice
all of that song with this movie came
out it's kind of eerie but of this
proves my chaos there he is
is it hey we have three votes to get
through but yeah what drastic world
coming out we figured this via go under
on his thoughts on um I guess we should
just do an order uh first of all we
actually saw again at mobile cotton they
were running it on on TV I think obvious
cousin it's still pretty awesome awesome
fascinating cuz when we saw this film I
mean it's the most we've ever saw movie
in the theaters I saw it 11 times
because there was always somebody who
hadn't seen it I'm like you thank
dressed that's something that's been
it's the same thing that happened to me
I ended up seeing it seven times it
really was when I think bad like
everybody has that quote-unquote
nostalgic summer post your nostalgic
summers in the comment section but then
nostalgic summer when you remember back
when you were a kid and in some cases
for some of you they'll be like three
years ago but um for us it was a longer
time ago and like why I think man just
the perfect summer I mean there's always
like to be a young kid or a early teens
or something when everything was just
right and for high school started you
know in the end worried about college
and the bills and mortgages and cut
anyway um 1993 the summer of 93 lion
Kane came out as yanking we had Jurassic
Park we were still in that era of
filmmaking where you could still have
things like what Terminator 2 is what
the year before some like there yeah um
just the fugitive would come up next
year I think 93 also had a league of
their own which was ya know just good
girl crying in baseball
um yeah and I always just we end of the
visiting friends back in Chicago we were
living in Seattle at the time and I
always just remember like every single
set of friends that I had had not seen
Jurassic ours is amazing
yes I goes push so hard as a poor you
want to see dinosaurs or in some case or
in some cases they had a friend of a
friend who had seen a DML like as a pork
oh yeah I mean I've seen again so yeah
you saw it 11 times I saw it seven times
so uh yeah and I I have not seen the
closest I've come
I saw guardians of the galaxy Dark
Knight and the Lord of the Rings movies
I saw all of those three times each
I try I know one of the Lord of the
Rings I've seen four times that's those
are the closest I've had to sit down
think about what movies I've seen like
you know like under than Tirzah how many
times more but no addressee Park is the
most and what's fascinating to watch it
now and max I'm hoping the cat and I can
make that board but what's best thing
you're watching it now is that when you
are noticing sort of the the mistakes
from a writing and directing point of
you not necessarily film the holes
though there definitely are those two uh
but just the the set up is especially
the set up uh in the first third seems
Donnie are you trying to say that David
Koepp writes clunky expose I we we make
my damocat belong really uh and uh but
but it's kind of writing in spider-man
was so amazing Jamie Shan you shine
alleged it's use Oh gah be out of your
mind
um but but yet the opening especially
like there's a lot of exposition and
they get it by pretty fast
I mean to apply when I was a kid I did
not follow what was going on with like
the embryos I mean I kind of got the
basic a okay he's taken the embryos to
open another part that's just kind of
what I thought I didn't know just
somebody evil while one sees embryo the
industrial espionage but again it it's
definitely bad feeling trade seasons but
it doesn't really matter it you want you
to the dinosaurs and that's what they do
when you set up these characters that
are kind of cartoons about their very
likable cartoons uh and they're cool
cartoon so it's like let's I'm fine with
it I'll because you look identified with
them very quickly um watching Jeff
Goldblum now he's both a delight
ah I mean it's because you remember old
so are you a big of a dinosaur this is
where most people are age most kids were
introduced to Jeff Goldblum the glory
that is and you just go goofy he is and
at the time this way of talking was like
kind of nude putting um in a sentence
was not like a big thing back then and
then you're like oh like this is it till
like this is all there is so it's one of
those things where it's both really
delightful and just you want to punch
him in the face if I feel honestly I
could watch him all day in this one lost
worlds where I lose it but yeah ya know
here's a side character at least and
uh-uh-uh
apart from uh go and let's not forget uh
Sam you and his amazing disappearing
reappearing accent so we were talking
about this hey the dog I want this
younger they like what makes Sam Neill
so appealing in the eyebrows you just in
general yeah love it is the attitudes
eyebrows you know it movement is
anything it's got a little bit of us
yeah it's not light sort of Smurfs Mac
and the other secret is when he speaks
everything he says sounds like he's
giving you a dire warning we might all
be okay but we might know yeah he talks
like everything's okay now
but it won't be and we don't know when
uh and and he doesn't I I again I love
him he's if you guys want a great time
there's a show on Netflix called peaky
blinders watch it because it is Sam
Neal's chewing scenery left him right
and I'm like oh I fist you but you know
even though looking back and remember
like with a lot of these actors I saw go
back and forces with Lord Durand I
remember liking her uh find in the movie
and then my mom actually ruined her
performance for me because all she would
call her he's mumbles she mumbles
everything everything she does is mumble
then I listen to him like she hates God
eats her in that movie yeah I'm
fascinated I don't hate her but no but
then I started with our mom gets like
she attaches that there's certain just
weird things that she like goes nuts
about him like that was one of them
where she's like Oh Lord she was the
only thing in that movie that was
terrible
said Wow and I like to go up our mom's
Mickey Mouse um but you know what but
watching it wasn't just that it was
stuff like sort of the action chick
aspect I don't think she was pulling off
very well I mean like there's one part
where it's like the bones just fall and
then they do like this we're close-up
where she's like they're they've all
follow there's no Raptor and she just
goes and it's really weird shot it's
just like it's um explore turns Tomb
Raider it's like where did that by - run
run run yeah it's these real weird
little moments in an otherwise decent
performance she does mumble which is
annoying those daedrea better than to
mess with nice with like you take some
Oldham takes off his head will get EMS
hurry up I owe kakuka he'll pay you so
uh in memory of major you takes his head
off I guess he's the asshole but guy you
in that predicament um but but the
should all be destroyed um but I ship
what else was I gonna say oh no I'm air
about Laura Dern the one thing I mean
she she does okay but the one thing she
really sells when we were watching again
uh when they're at the dinner table
scene and they're talking about what
they think crystal Gold's argument total
bullshit oh my god I mean we're not
talking about something that was taken
out by humans
I'm sure chose dinosaurs more extinction
yep they're not gardeners if you yeah
cuz we're not part of nature's so if you
can't adapt to humans or if nature
creates humans I'm and I'm sure nature
will find a way to wipe our fucking hair
human essence I plan it someday but to
be like well that doesn't count like
that no it's total bullshit yeah so
scientist I hate discovery really sucks
it's raping the world is he gonna
fucking scientist Oh what's so great
about discovering Wow well me that
you're a scientist taking a natural
green light yeah uh no and just to
emphasize that doesn't mean like nuke
the whales perhaps maybe bad at all like
I think we do have a responsibility
although the argument in that scene does
not make sense we have a total
responsibility to the planet I'm not
bringing that but I'm arguing like he
makes the same mistake it's the exact
same mistake that people who were just
like I have fucked the planet which it
removes humans from the environmental
equation oh oh like humans don't count
as nature cuz we can blow things up and
ever it's like well we got here somehow
we evolved here somehow
if you remove us from the equation
that's not helping us either and the
other winners over me we're people and
that's the environment so we're totally
different things it's like that both yet
it's both sides to the extreme but what
I'll say is that Laura Dern in that
scene and by the way I'm not sure
bringing condos the Condors back is a
great idea who the hell knows how they
would adapt in the environment like you
know after we've completely cut down
half their forests and shit well but but
that but that's the thing with Laura
Dern in this and then yeah hurry when
she makes the argument it's not like
fucking Denise Richards and the James
Bond boys Christmas Jones or something
it's like you are not a fucking
scientist I'm not buying this for a man
like she is totally credible and she
says that line with great weight but not
like he noticed this performance yeah
kind of thing is like you have totally
Xhosa and you die I totally agree with
her he's like and she approaches it from
the dinosaurs perspective as well
because she's like you have plan you
know they don't go into it they go into
in the book but they've got plants that
are poisonous to the dinosaurs that
they're actually eating you know and
she's like we have no idea what the hell
this environment looked like 65 million
years ago you have plants here you think
they look pretty they may be poisonous
you know that may work the other way you
may bring plants back that are poisonous
to humans who knows and these creatures
have no idea what century it is and
they're going to defend themselves
violently if necessary you know and do
what they can to survive it's like these
things were not meant to be together
it's a way more compelling argument than
go blooms ah ah okay on Sam now we saw
for humans we saw huh
and a way for the second movie I will
make that argument a lot again with us
won't get that but let's finish up this
one uh the diet the facts on the
dinosaurs still looked you know hold
already damn good I got you hello
often more nowadays but it's like for a
boomy this old for the effects to like
you know I can just barely tell this is
that's pretty damn impressive
let's keep something in mind like all
you children out there ye Millennials
who may not have grown up with his
masterpiece like we have this was this
this was practically the stone Age's of
CGI I mean this is mr. Knight or two we
had Terminator 2 we had the abyss we had
Terminator 2 and we had been much young
Sherlock Holmes had the stained glass
monster Star Trek 2 at the Genesis
planet we have the Death Star effects in
jet like bits and pieces here there but
a movie with CGI to this degree like oh
we're just going to recreate dinosaurs
you know it's easier much easier to sit
there and say well we're going to create
this metal monster that's reflective it
doesn't have to look like it has that
much texture it's just metal
it's the t1000 you know it will morph it
you can there you don't have to be as
obsessed with getting it to look right
to create a motherfucking dinosaur and
not only that but a bunch of them and
you have to believe that they're really
there and it has to match the
animatronic that you have that's also
supposed to look realistic both work
wonderfully amazing they tell I can tell
the difference but you know but just
very just well you can tell the
difference because even even if you know
what I'm trying to do even yeah even as
good as jp's effects are you can still
tell well at CGI like not nowhere near
as bad as modern films and I swear to
god like this if you look at older
movies with blue screening technology
you will sometimes find that the earlier
films did it better because they were so
obsessed with getting it to look right
and real that they through all their
effort into it and then you'll see
random films from years later it's like
how can the blue screen suck this bad I
think it's kind of like at some point
you just don't care yeah I think also
because it was the first time they're
doing dinosaurs and I want to look real
I mean they had to get the skin textures
and the movements and all these are
things and they had to look at now
movies nowadays a little bets saved on
disk now just put that in this movie
change the color and the wrinkles change
the size and the look and it's
essentially the same thing and I think
that's possible and I think part of it
too is just it's over you
it's there's something that Mad Max just
proved that you could still do practical
effects it looks more real
well it doesn't you make in the writer
and you CG to help enhance that instead
of being the focus and like that's
honestly the problem I have with most
films today that you CGI it looks really
fake you know sounds like we got more do
see better
they're doing better business I'm a
vacuum uh I think is 100 percent
convincing uh like I can look at that
and be like I know it has to be a
computer because there's no other way
but okay but even okay like here's a
good example from Spielberg's own
library
Indiana Jones for yeah I might even
argue lost world in many respects I do
not love it look very good in yeah like
it's almost just like once you've done
it once and you so nailed and got it
perfect that's like well now they
believe it we don't have to worry about
it is like no you should worry about it
more and there's something where they're
sort of taking from what they've already
learned instead of doing it from scratch
again I think again it's sort of like if
you get something from a store or
something that was made in a village
individually by someone I don't know
what else but I think the other thing is
- did the animatronics help yeah
nowadays everything is CGI you wouldn't
I'm wondering how much in Jurassic world
is going to be from the trailers it
looks like it's it looks like nothing
yeah and the animatronic don't give me
an WA trying to tell because for a while
you're looking at something real it's
funny the Raptor sequence in the kitchen
I forgot how much actual puppetry was
there yeah every time I see that was
like man I always remember thinking that
this is going to be all CGI and it's
like there are puppets everywhere
puppets animatronics any any way they
could do it outside of CGI it's like
once or twice like hardly at all is it
CGI he hops up on the table
that's CGI like no they were she I'm
sorry she and when I walk in that CGI
yeah but the so much out the closing on
the door now is CGI that I me again I
just watched this and I'm just like you
know I know that has to be CGI but it
looks really real
it looks so convincing um so yeah we
really like this movie cuz probably but
in huge ground brain and I think great
summer blockbuster
my childhood like I want to relive
seeing that movie again for the first
time Jurassic well we kind of did that's
one of a few movies when they re
released it's like let's see this again
oh hell yeah it was legitimately
nostalgic yeah um it was amazing even
watching it now on TV it's missed it I
think it's where we got the idea to do
the review because when we saw we are
kind of making jokes here and there a
torrent just like I think we can review
this actually but there's still things
to pick apart I mean the script is not
particularly strong um the characters
are kind of cutouts but I think they got
good actors for the most part to see how
that's in them I'm just gonna say it
Michael Crichton as an author was one of
those people who wrote really great
ideas it's like oh my god Jurassic Park
and they were very intense you know in
drama strains fear great tramer they
were always great ideas in lost world as
a book anyway no no no was it what did
he do was a Westworld oh yeah that I
thought you said lost world it but his
characters are all douchebags they were
like really mean-spirited and I know
there's some people that are so married
to the book like I can't I just can't
deal with what Spielberg did I Amand
like turning him into this nice guy and
I'm like really I didn't care because
like there was nobody in the Jurassic
Park book I was like I could care less
if any of these people ever die even
though a like even the grandkids come
came off as annoying somehow like in the
book so it well that's why I'm wondering
if that's why lost world went that
direction that's why it went
uber dark over I mean I'll see that's
advanced of no more money that's more
like I couldn't give a shit this is my
primal lost world I could not give a
shit if any of those people in the movie
lived or died not uh the the worst very
much like the book no the worst bit of
writing in that movie I mean it is
painful to watch whenever I see this bit
and this is the writing I mean the
directing phase of part two but this is
the writing
anyways ever kept script yeah you know
it was definitely feel works golden no
no no no because this I always hear his
name a pop puffeth wait I think it's how
you say his name the hunter in the
second movie uh-huh when he's introduced
in the film and he's on this holiday he
says you know it's just like during this
Chase is like the dinosaurs are right
let's go all right we're gonna be
listening to me for about five minutes
talk to this guy am i exposition at my
background here we go I am hunting the
t-rex that is what I am looking on and
I'm like you can't be this lazy you
can't be this all day but kept of course
you can I mean it's one of those things
we just watch it's like are you really
this lays yeah um so but I mean apart
from that uh it's much darker which
we've established we don't mind do you
know if a society can argue Becky buddy
I just didn't care about anybody then
but yeah you bring coal go down this is
star level which is a huge Oh such a
disaster um he got rid of two of his
kids somehow now he's only got one um
this is this would have been post
Independence Day so he's already the
one-liner master that mommy's very angry
on Jim did Julia Julianne Moore who's
usually great but he she hasn't missed
once in a while and she's just totally
forgettable in this oh I like a role in
Hannibal which is like apart from just
doing a Jodie Foster impression like you
left no impression on me yeah again in
Manama yeah this is not a like to chew
him more I think is one of the great
actresses ya know when she nails a it's
like she's something she's chillingly
boy and that's a compliment we're saying
like when she nails it she's chillingly
good but that's the flip side is
sometimes when you don't nail something
in you're that good it could be a big
disaster
well I'm even with this on see she's
just forgettable when she's bad she's
just forgettable yes it's just bad at
anything
no no impression is Vaughn oh my god I
said oh my god this guy's the worst he's
going nowhere and I hated him for years
because he would always pick these
dramas they start doing comedies and got
a little better and now we're sort of
wishing he stopped with the comedies
because they're known as the Vince Bunco
know I'll still say to my dying day he's
a great comedian I love it like even in
bad comedies at least I mean why aren't
his performances fine this is just
stupid movie but he swear that I have
not seen anything where I thought he
could hold a dramatic role no oh I mean
I like this selfie he can come like
which is worse you think the cell or
this movie uh for Vince Vaughn
performance know you know you know I'll
say I'll say this movie for
one life but Hammond did pack up back-up
plan really what's that me and it's like
that was supposed to be your badass
moment that was the Harrison Ford you
know pack tobacco play was that me I
mean like the people to know he commits
him in open air me I mean it's like it
is Vince Vaughn in their first one and
get off my plane
yeah I wasn't that yeah what's wrong
with him oh but but yeah I mean just
Clara he was not doing comedies yet they
didn't know what to do with them he I
doubt he knew what to do with him and he
was a douche but they were all doing
them all and not for like hey they're
supposed to be awful like into Michael
here's the ring if I'm going places
they're supposed to be environmental as
you're supposed to be rooting for summer
putting people's lives in danger yeah
constantly delete I can replace that
guy's ammo at some point I'm like you're
a fucking murderer yeah you are a
motherfucker ex I won't be getting oh
great how many fucking people are gonna
be evil eye on my parents and my pants
I'm not humming alright you are an awful
awful human being and that's all deserve
to get eaten by dinosaurs yeah no that
was the inspiring see now is the end
then John Hammonds suddenly the bad guy
guy right now you're Jon Hamm and now
you're the awful person yet he gets the
nice grandfather's features of Ed nobody
fuckin day I come from my varied as I
just kept minor cut to John number what
the hell is this I thought everybody
liked it down in the beginning of the
movie trying to help you be blonde and
then yeah now you're John Hammond no no
I must swear word apparently I can't you
people here to help fix my mistakes and
only whatever my sides blood-sucking
Moya and fucking fits fine oh no and
then you had yeah this villain that they
try to shoehorn in that you don't even
recognize half the tag is either in a
hat or glasses or something and he and
he's the business suit that evil suits
were doing that and the whole movie the
the whole movie is just constructed in
cliches yeah it literally just is
constructed entirely out of cliches way
worse than the book I will say this the
book is better but that's not saying
much because I thought is a sequel like
when I read lost world because I've read
it well before the movie came
I'm like who Amory Kurt secret to
Jurassic Park I'm like and this is just
a cheap way to make more money Michael
crying got it somebody demanded sequel
wrote your paycheck end of story there's
no reason there's no second island
either it just go back to the original
is such a pointless fricking book and
I'm like the only thing the movie did
better was bring that dinosaur to San
Diego so at least I got a pen - we got a
little something these I got a better
gut Zilla film out of it than Godzilla
ended up being um but but that is crazy
white listen stupid I mean it's need to
see serious Felicity long that movie
just drags on ya ever and it's not fun
the first one looked beautiful and you
saw a dinosaurs and the majesty of
dinosaurs nak if you won't go dark in
the second one that's fine but you are
looking at grey throughout the whole
entire thing and it is just ugly and
unpleasant and not enjoyable and not
smart enough to warrant the dream you
mean watching Jeff go boom run around
shouting Sarah
rrraaahhh Sarah and I it doesn't excite
you the people that like this movie I
don't get it I cannot grasp it it is
just let's go be hustling to me know cuz
there's a lot of people say you again
it's like the Stephen King or and you
lay off I'm only gonna watch this nine
more times and make it a really popular
Murphy all the dressing fire - it's got
it's got two really good action scenes
the - time and uh yeah we're yeah that
valves which again the result of human
stupidity yeah and like random play me
with your leg woman that scene I'm like
why are you but no no no no I ran
okay right so my 3aa like why why are
you bringing that thing in so bezel
resolved their own stupidity and then
the the second scene the ending it with
the whole t-rex running down San Diego
which I remember seeing a movie going
wow this isn't in the book and this is
the most fucking ridiculous thing I've
ever seen but you know I remember it Oh
totally I'm like I will totally remember
this is just being so what the hell I
mean I was that shit insane crazy
because I'm so blown away that it was
happening I kind of couldn't comprehend
whether it was good or bad he was just
so strange I was like I'm really I'm
seeing these dinosaurs I've seen 11
times on the theater before suddenly
like in suburbia it just yet dogs and
yeah in the ending I'm like this is I I
don't know what every many grew berries
like old Jurassic Park 3 it's just a
self satire of the whole series know if
you want any proof that this thing
turned into a self sad tired the entire
facing the entire way yeah yeah that
that entire last 20 minutes of lost
world I'm like okay we're just spoofing
Jurassic Park now like Spielberg is like
winking at his like see we ran out of
ideas you know the one thing I will say
is that they have apparently said that
this was like one of the Elmo's like the
first use of Skype or whatever bells
like one of the first times like a
director kind of directed a film through
Skype um you know it through something
very similar because his child was
really sick and we he went home to be
with his kid and he directed it through
these video mom may explain some don't
know I'm not honestly and I say this
like I still think this is an awful
movie but I mean really then that's a
good human being that's a really cool
guy shut up uh that's a really cool guy
to do that um to actually like be like
you know what this is important I'm
gonna do my best my family comes first
like this oh my you'll I have nothing
personal against yeah movie sucked in
you know the toons made some of my
favorite films of all time including the
first Jurassic yeah
oh no and for a guy to make this many
big films and honestly like to have as
many of them as good as they are in as
groundbreaking as they are like it it's
an accomplishment well I think we'll
still kind of make fun of them because
there's stuff to make fun of but it's
like and to do
publish Muslim either of us weasels
coverage by the fact that it's a crappy
book yeah so I mean you're starting from
crap so you can only make it better make
it the same or make it worse and in this
case it it came out the same because in
with the ending is so crazy it kind of
just makes it better because of like
what the fuck t-rex chasing people
around San Diego but the same time all
of the crappy things in the book in the
first half he kind of made even worse so
oh that's Jurassic Park - let's talk
about Jurassic Park 3 we gave up uh
which is a well which in some respects I
almost argue makes it better than the
semi tell me you gotta sound good sorry
and I know this will horrify so many you
I actually just like lost world more
than I dislike Jurassic Park 3 cuz
Jurassic Park 3 basically all they did
they were like here's the business pitch
meeting let's do a drastic park sequel
ok what Sam Neill doing right away
paycheck all right he's in if it's just
this moment okay um let's grab Joe
Johnston let's throw some dinosaurs oh
let's turn that pterodactyl scene that
we never threw in the first movie and
let's make it nice and mercifully short
yes
let's say yeah no it's not IRA metals oh
yeah no we're not going to say jack shit
we're just going to cut straight to some
action scenes boom boom boom boom hour
and a half later you're out of the
theater you ate your popcorn and you're
done and that's it like I'm sorry it it
went faster than lost world lost world
was such a boring slog than I went up
you know what this movie is stupid and
it sucks but it knows it's stupid it
knows it sucks it's not even trying it's
not even trying to say anything it's
just like all right you want dinosaurs
for an hour and a half boom there you go
done it's a it's efficient it's a
b-movie
yeah it's a really shitty at least at
being a b-movie
I'm like lost world which is Frank so
hard to say things yes and fail yeah um
and and I'll say this too we at the very
least we had Sam Neill throughout the
movie which even him in an alcohol I
think I'd just be so entertaining and
cool I'm sorry I'll take Sam neo over
jeffco if it was a god as a star
I would have taken them together again
but as if it's if it's the star of the
film
sam neill / go blue man yeah i mean any
day but then i shit that stupid him and
laura dern breaking up like that pissed
me off I'm sorry it's like to end the
first film with them he has stopped
fucking kids in his arms English tell
them and they smile he looks out a
window
divorce or split up I'm sorry Ali I
changed my story okay now don't want to
conceive yeah and she said the movies so
I don't even if she just stayed home or
something or her was pregnant or had
like another job or something that
required her I said fuck you you're
insane I'm not going back to this island
anything anything but don't break them
up there's no point cheer Leonie
oh my god oh yeah
here's that she's really bad it's really
it is a close call cuz sometimes I'm
like man maybe I do like loss me
whenever I'm in a mood to say a like
lost world more than Jurassic italiani
cuz he's the reason why cuz I'm like she
is so inseparable not since Kate Capshaw
in Temple of Doom yeah have I seen
somebody so painful oh I love you again
I don't know I'm just got standing with
my mouth open like Bella
oh I'm concerned now Oh William H Macy's
totally wasted you could have put it oh
yeah I roll I am I'm cooperating here I
might going to help you with the
dinosaur is it would it be I you know I
was guessing wouldn't be funnier if he
had more like that character but I guess
he kind of did but just you but what can
I was hoping they would pull some random
fucking twist out of he'd be like the
villain or something that really would
go with that would go into lost world
carrot or be like a total cower to me
like well I have fun son and wife and
I'm divorcing I I'm taking off in this
plane later yeah yes the die stars
kidnapper and then like a part of a
scheme for me it was the only thing it
was worth it for was I liked the
pterodactyl scene pterodactyl was cool
um the my favorite is like
the Don Davis is like score where it's
is like and here's some Brachiosaurus so
play the Jaypee thing really fast and I
know
well I that was a fun moment oh God do
they look terrible to mo I see they've
all got rid of that purple source from
the kool-aid days when it was like you
know I think I'll just call a purple
dinosaur Rex aquinas or yeah yeah that's
not what it looked like it was
advertising some kids product they look
awful um but at least it had at least
had some yonks at least I had some color
unlike the last one it knew it literally
was a theme park ride that's all it was
and the thing is it's it's a pick your
poison again ever people which is like
Las World War like that's fine I don't
care
all I'm gonna say is for some people you
know you might like lost world more and
for some people you might like Jurassic
Park three more just because it's so
short and knows exactly what it is is an
hour-and-a-half theme park ride that
doesn't try doesn't really give a shit
but at least it's just like there you're
done whereas lost world that like tried
so hard and tried to say so many things
and then and does 16th on any of them
giant casts and and said all we get his
prints mom running around shooting
dinosaurs it was ugly it was just an
ugly film to look at you know we're at
least with three you had Sam Neill it
was short and not a great selling point
but uh but at least it was colorful and
you had something new with the
pterodactyls uh you know and again and
not not huge selling points it's not
good but yeah and Lisa gave us a little
something I just it just bothers me that
twice now the only thing lost world
added was the San Diego chase which I
thought was inventive so I'm wondering
off the cliff I argue a little bit too
because I Rex is cool you know and
hanging off the cliff now because nobody
was hanging off a truck somewhere in a
Jurassic Park you have a glass break you
know some cool it's a cool scene but
what have you added new to this story
oh yeah no just nothing nothing new it
just bothers me that twice in a row
they just remade the movie again and
there just was nothing new added to it
like right down to Jeff : spouting the
same bullshit yeah
bah-bah something someone can control ok
if you want to make a good sequel just
eradicate the word again here we go
again
why not doing again and this time those
are the word on it Oh what's is me oh no
you're making all the same mistakes
again I'm like yes you get it yeah no
that's exactly it it's like why you know
we're not doing this again you are doing
it again we don't want to see it again
we can see the first one again to see it
again we want to see something new we
wants you to progress so that is the
only thing right now like Jurassic world
no idea what its gonna be I'm trying to
keep an open mind the only thing I like
about it I like what Lisa looks like a
real theme park this time this might be
fun to give it live right down and it's
not like oh there's a site B or C or D
or oh we're just going back to the same
site be fucking Island again and I I'm
just hedging my bets now they haven't
come out for release greetings bad sign
uh you got Chris Pratt on a motorcycle
he's the Raptor Whisperer on this
motorcycle with the Raptors riding
alongside him this is gonna be bad this
is gonna be awful but whether or not
it's gonna be awful awful I would if I'm
waiting at the very least we can get a B
movie like a party I did not conceive
this being a guy who loved I loved the
first Jurassic Park so the kid in me
just hopes it's good i I my guess I'm
opening what we want to guess this
Pippin but my guess is that it's really
gonna be bad but will it be bad
enjoyable or bad not enjoyable maslow
both ways the first one got some issues
but still loving one of my own babies
all a change so may things second one
tried really hard and failed really
slowly and third one didn't try it all
failed really quickly so for the sequels
to be their own poison yeah I would
rather not try it all and fail quickly
then try really hard to fail oh so
slowly so um there you go there it is so
Google and
we'll probably see you after Jurassic
world so later Nick Nick Nick Nick